[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
François patria bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sénateur de la Côte d'Or
président du groupe RDP ici au Sénat
c'est les ce sont les sénateurs de la
majorité présidentielle on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par Christelle Bertrand du
groupe La Dépêche bonjour Christelle
bonjour hianne bonjour François patri
bonjour on va évidemment parler de la
loi immigration François patria vous
avez participé hier au dîner des
ministres et des cadres de la majorité à
l'Élysée autour d'Emmanuel Macron que
vous a dit le chef de l'État le chef de
l'État a dit une chose d'abord la
situation telle qu'elle était d'évoquer
la gravité de la situation il l' évoqué
de gravité en second lieu il a évoqué
l'idée de pouvoir être offensif
et de pouvoir aboutir à un accord et en
second lieu en 3oisème lieu ce que le
choix chef de l'État c'est qu'on puisse
garder l'unité de la majorité qui doit
être
renforcée non elle est pas menacée mais
elle doit être gardée au bout pour pour
qu'on puisse avancer avancer sur ce
texte et avancer sur d'autres textes
ensuite garder l'unité de la majorité ça
veut dire modifier le texte du Sénat je
je ne pense pas que sur ce texte je ne
pense pas vraiment malgré tout ce qu'on
a pu dire ou écrire il y a il y a la
grande majorité des parlementaires de de
la majorité sont sont reste soudé
aujourd'hui il peut s'agir de quelques
individualités à côté je crois qu'on
surestime ce qui pourrait être
défaillant je pense que sur l'essentiel
la majorité se retrouvera sur les
décisions qui seront prises donc allez
vite ça veut dire euh convoquer une CMP
très rapidement comme l'a souhaité le
chef de l'État vous avez fixé une
date je pense que je pense comme les
chefs de l'État que le le temps est
facteur de divergence si on laisse les
jours s'écoulés comme le souhaitent
certains on va voir les positions
maximalistes s'exprimer on va voir
chacun rester se rigidifier sur sa sur
sa position je ne suis pas sûr que dans
il on affaiblisse les on affaiblisse les
forces en gagnant du temps je crois que
plutôt que cela je crois qu'il faut
maintenant aller à la commission mixte
paritaire on a 4 jours pour la préparer
si elle a lieu lundi je pense qu'elle
peut avoir lieu lundi lundi je pense que
j'espère je souhaite qu'elle a lieu
lundi on en a parlé hier avec le
président de la commission c'est la date
que souhaite c'est c'est la date sou je
so je souhaite le président de la
commission des lois on a donc 4 jours
qui va la convoquer donc ce sera lundi
c'est la date qu' souhaite je pense que
sera lundi je le pense oui euh on a donc
4 jours pour discuter des modalités des
positions des choses sur lesquelles on
peut évoluer il faudra de part et
d'autres qu'il y ait des conessions vous
savez sur ce texte la majorité le
gouvernement était prêt à négocier avec
avec les oppositions à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a eu un débat de plus de
40 he en commission plus de 40 he en
commission qui avait abouti à un texte
ce texte il était pas figé il était prêt
à être négocié avec l'ensemble des même
des oppositions est parti côté hier soir
vous AV et vous avez compris quand même
que c'est les oppositions réunies dans
un contexte assez surprenant qui ont
fait en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de
discussion du texte vudra m'expliquer
quand même comment les républicains qui
réclamament un texte sur l'immigration
depuis des mois et des mois au moment où
on veut faire passer ce texte refuse
d'en discuter dis qu'il était dé tricoté
non non mais attendez c'est ce qu'
disent que c'est plus du tout la version
du Sénat et que défend la version du sén
le rôle du Parlement c'est justement de
il est arrivé combien de fois que le
Sénat détricote des textes de
l'Assemblée nationale et après on en a
discuté et après on a abouti à des
accords sur beaucoup de textes donc
c'est pas c'est pas si vous voulez un a
priori c'est pas une justification que
le fait était détricoté en commission B
ça appelle le lendemain des discussions
et des débats et des évolutions et j'ai
CR comprendre que Gérald armanin a été
ouvert il était ouvert il était ouvert
en débattre et avoir comment pouvait
avancer pour les solutions de compromis
mais refuser de déb chambigé est-ce
qu'il y a pas eu ambigué aussi de la
part de Géral ramanin qui quand il était
au Sénat soutenait la version
sénatoriale puis qui après a semblé
soutenir la version de la commission des
lois de l'Assemblée qui était différente
de la version sénatoriale est-ce qu'il a
pas fait des fautes Politi je je pense
au contraire que Gérald daranin que j'ai
trouvé hier matin à la
fois responsable offensif et dans le
même temps totalement lucide sur la
situation il a essayé au Sénat de dire
voilà il a rev dit avant
ce que vous proposerez nous vous nous
aiderons à le faire voter ensuite on le
discutera et si nous-même nous
avons approuver ce texte c'est parce que
nous pensions qu'il était un texte qui
donnait des gages à l'Assemblée
nationale pour pouvoir trouver des
solutions de repli mais nous avions bien
dit que le texte tel qu'il était écrit
ici ne nous convenait pas mais qu'il
permettait d'ouvrir ce débat or ce débat
les républicains l'ont refusé justement
le texte qui sort d'ici ne vous convenz
pas est-ce que vous vous êtes mis
d'accord hier soir sur les lignes rouges
que vous imposeriez et euh les sujets
sur lesquels vous pourriez être plus
souple notamment il y a un point qui a
été essentiel dans les discussions c'est
le la suppression de laame est-ce que le
sujet a été évoqué hier soir lors de
lors de cette discussion vous savez si
on met des lignes rouges des totems on
navance pas donc ça veut dire que la
suppression la aujourd'hui n'est plus on
avance pas on avavance pas je je pense
que chaque point du texte point par
point doit être aujourd'hui discuté
négocier voir si on peut
simplement faire des concessions de part
et d'autrre sur le texte tel qu'il est
venu du Sénat voir au contraire s'il
faut garder l'essentiel des mesures dont
ont besoin les français pour lutter
contre l'immigration clantestine et pour
pouvoir réagir à cette situation c'est à
négocier demain sur le problème de laame
la première ministre a déjà répondu cela
peut faire l'objet d'une réflexion et
d'un texte à part dans le futur mais
est-ce que vous pourez le laisser dans
le texte aujourd'hui je viens de vous
répondre ça peut aujourd'hui non mais
attendez ça peut être demain on peut
discuter de laame et dire demain on va
on pourra le gouvernement l'a dit on
pourrait faire peut-être un texte à part
sur ce sujet après avoir consulté
attendez après avoir consulté le Conseil
constitionnel ou Conseil d'État au
minimum parce que vous avez compris
qu'il
s'agit non mais il s'agit d'un cavalier
non mais il s'agit d'un cavalier
législatif enfin faut pas qu'ils veulent
tout et leur contraire est-ce que les LR
oui ou non veulent qu'il y ait des
mesures plus coercitives pour lutter
contre l'immigration dans ce pays vous
nêils y mettent des conditions ça veut
dire qu'en fin de compte ils ne veulent
pas vous avez compris que les
républicains dans ce dans ce contexte ne
cherche pas un texte politique on voit
bien ils n pas ils nont pas discuté ils
cherchent un gain politique je trouve
que c'est une petite attitude face à des
difficultés que que nous retrouvons
d'ailleurs partout en Europe et contre
lequel la France a agi quand elle a
sous-présidence française pter un texte
européen donc pour que ce soit clair la
majorité n'est pas prête à maintenir la
suppression de la me dans le texte qui
sera proposé au vote au vote après la
CMP moi je pense que sur les prestations
sociales et sur la me ça peut faire
partie des irritants qui pe donc il faut
le retirer du Tex est-ce que non mais
est-ce que mais qui est pas vraiment une
suppression le Sénat n'a pas voté la
suppression de laame il a voté sa
transformation en avec un réduit mais
mais je vous dis sur la il y a deux ou
trois points durs est-ce que sur ces
deux ou trois points durs en
contrepartie du fait que nous pouvons
aussi céder sur d'autres points je crois
qu'il faudra se concentrer sur les
articles du milieu qui sont entre
l'article 4 B et l'article le 8 9 qui
sont très très importants il y a des
mesures dedans importantes nous nous
avons accepté ici au Sénat des mesures
coeritives difficiles nous avons et que
nous avons même soutenu en l'occurrence
parfois l'assemblée d'ailleurs nous le
reproche ici nous l'avons soutenu est-ce
que est-ce que demain il n'est pas
important la seule chose importante
demain c'est que nous soyons dotés d'un
texte qui permettre aux forces de
l'ordre la justice d'avoir des mesures
coeritives et je crois que c'est ça
l'essentiel et j'espère parce que moi je
je fais confiance quand même au membres
de la CMP pour j'allais dire dépasser
leur le leur petit intérêt politique euh
minimaliste et à proximal pour penser à
l'intérêt général de ce qu'attend les
Français est-ce que c'est un message que
vous adressé aussi à sachaer parce que
sacholier il était très dur avec le
texte du Sénat il en voulait pas vous
l'avez vu hier soir est-ce qu'il est
prêt à mettre de l'eau dans son vin pour
aboutir à un compromis j'ai vu hier soir
Sacha alier il est prêt à suivre la
méthode que je viens d'évoquer
aujourd'hui si on fait il faudra des
concessions de par aut SICI les
sénateurs républicains disent c'est appr
prendre ou à laisser évidemment ça sert
à rien de faire une commission mix
paritaire si c'était cela vous savez
bien que sur la me Bruno r on a fait une
ligne rouge par exemple non mais non
mais on peut jamais on a vu un texte
arriver en commission mixte paritaire en
disant c'est ce texte là appr prendre ou
all glement ça n'est jamais arrivé on a
toujours dans les commissions mix
paritaire fait en sorte qu'il y ait des
concessions de part et d'autre et que le
texte s transformé donc je pense que
comme comme d'habitude euh demain enfin
lundi et bien dans cette commission mix
paritaire chacun saura faire de son côté
les pas nécessaires pour arriver à un
texte qui sera peut-être le juste
nécessaire qu' au moins queon garde tous
les éléments nécessaires pour qu'il soit
efficace tel que le demandent
aujourd'hui les Français et que le
propose géralde darin donc ça veut dire
que le texte sera plus dur que le texte
qui est sorti de la commission des lois
de l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que vous
êtes sûr que l'aile gauche de votre
parti le votera je pense que s'il y a un
accord global et que si ce texte il sera
forcément plus dur puisque aujourd'hui
la position en commission mixte
paritaire est plus favorable à
l'opposition je pense qu'il n'y aura pas
de problème pour que sa majorité le vote
je ne crois pas un instant que notre
groupe que le groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale se divisera sur le sujet group
donc il passera le vote ce sera qu'and
mardi du coup nous souhaitons mardi oui
donc CMP lundi vote mardi est-ce que si
jamais la CMP n'aboutit pas qu'est-ce
que vous faites est-ce que vous retirez
le texte je crois que le chef de l'État
s'est exprimé sur le sujet je pense que
la position je vu ce matin confirmé hier
soir plutôt ce serait plutôt que s'il
n'y avait pas de CMP positif ça veut
dire que les oppositions ne souhaitent
pas qu'il ait un texte sauf le leur
maximalisé que dans ce cas dans ce
cas-là il faut constater le fait que il
y a pas de majorité pour voter le texte
et que la responsabilité en incombe aux
oppositions qui d'un côté ont maximalisé
deux l'ont Durc outrageusement et trois
on refusait de débattre donc si la CMP
n'était pas conclusive vous ne
présenteriez pas le texte dans l'ém
endez c'est pas c'est pas moi décider
c'est le gouvernement qui décide qui
décide je pense que je pense je pense
que le gouvernement aujourd'hui ne
souhaite ni 493 sou pas de 493 sur ce
texte je crois que la première ministre
l'avait dit le le chef de l'État l'a
confirmé hier soir ni 493 et que s'il y
avait un désaccord en CMP je vois pas
pourquoi le texte pourrait continuer
alors vous vous êtes prêt à à faire des
efforts pour aller plus dans le sens du
Sénat est-ce que vous craignez que la
droite du Sénat durcisse encore son
texte notamment sur l'article 3 devenu
l'article 4 bis sur la régularisation
des travailleurs sans papier si la la si
la la droite siénatoriale voulait en
plus d'cir le texte en plus je crois que
c'est ser qu'elle marquer la volonté
qu'elle ne veut pas texte et je vous le
dis je vous répète dis tout à l'heure il
cherche plutôt un gain politique qu'un
texte politique or nous avons besoin
d'un texte politique quand vous dites ça
ça veut dire que vous envisager la
possibilité que la droite ou maintienne
en tous les cas ses positions voir les
durcisses m qui l' envisage c'est vous
qui me posez la question mais quand vous
dites cherche plus un gain politiqueun
texte ça veut dire que vous les sentez
pas prêt à à négocier je dis que si leur
position est aussi rigide et dogmatique
de dire c'est ça ou rien c'est ça ma
position c'est ce que je vous explique
mais j'espère je pense que pendant les 4
jours qui viennent la raison va
l'emporter et que les oppositions qui
ont eu des gains et qui auront des gains
dans ce texte au bout puissent
comprendre que c'estes gains qu'ils ont
obtenu qu' seront rendront peut-être
plus efficace le texte en tout cas ils
le disent eux-mêmes et bien permettront
d'aboutir à un accord les républicains
qui euh avaient inscrit hier à l'ordre
du jour une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle notamment pour
permettre un référendum sur
l'immigration et pour faire primer le
droit national sur le droit européen
l'ont retiré à cause de division avec
les centristes ils ont ils ont eu raison
de le faire qu'avez-vous pensé de ce
retrait ben je pense que je pense que RV
Marseille en l'occurrence avait dit que
ces troupes ne voteraiit pas un texte
qui va contre les traités européens qui
l'on dit à partir de là euh avec 133
voix euh les républicains étaient dans
la mesure ce texte savez plutôt que
d'avoir un texte qui est rejeté ici là
encore le gain politique l'emporte ils
ont choisi la solution de la sages en
l'occurrence puisque que ce texte ne
serait pas passé quoi qu'il arrive
est-ce qu'avec ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée vous dites comme Gérald
haranin que aujourd'hui les républicains
sont la béquille du rassemblement
national la béquille ouais en
l'occurrence pour le r national les
républicains sont la béquille duurn ils
font la politique du pire c'est je ne
réemploierai pas ce mot mais je dirais
que maintenant la vérité éclate au grand
jour que les positions des républicains
irréductible je dis pas de tous
puisqu'il y a eu 12 républicains qui ont
été couragés au Sénat qui n'ont pas et
qui n'ont pas voté le rejet du
texted oui donc 22 sur 62 l' pas voui 22
22 parce qu'il y a eu 12 bon donc
euh aujourd'hui que les positions des
républicains qui ressemblaient de plus
en plus féocement au position du Front
national et à force de courir après les
positions du Front national maintenant
ils les ont rejoints et on voit bien que
ce vote qui est inadmissible d'un vote
sur un texte aussi politique aussi
important pour les Français le Front
national souhaite le chaos mais
maintenant montrer que eux aussi les
républicains préfèrent le chaos plutôt
que la responsabilité aujourd'hui
effectivement en l'occurrence il
favorise la montée du Front national en
position prenant ses positions parce que
les Français qui sont sur cette ligne là
préféront toujours aller directement au
fond que chez eux je pense que les
républicains vont y perdre beaucoup dans
cette affaire dans quel état d'esprit
avez-vous senti le président de la
République hier soir est-ce qui
s'interroge désormais sur la capacité à
gouverner dans les 4 ans qui qui
viennent et et à réformé profondément le
pays je CIS on voit que là on a passé un
cap quand même dans les blocages je
crois que la volonté de réformer du
président n'a jamais été aussi forte
mais la capacité on va partir demain la
capacité écoutez on va porter des sujet
va reprendre des sujets économiques il a
parlé du plein emploi ilci est beaucoup
employé cette semaine ça fait partie de
discussion ça hier soir bien sûr
aujourd'hui on va dire on va travailler
sur le premploi on va travailler sur ce
qui est logement on va travailler sur
les sujets sur l'agriculture on va
travailler sur la fin de vie et il
espère que des textes soient
encore puiss encore passer on on a passé
50 textes en un an et demi oui mais là
quelque chose a changé quand même dans
cette dedans il y a eu quand même des
textes difficiles comme les retraites il
y a eu des textes importants à
côté il y a eu aussi l'assurance chômage
il y en a eu quand même donc on va
poursuivre je crois que le chef de
l'État s'est projeté depuis déjà
plusieurs mois dans l'avance en disant
sur ces sur les 3 ans et demi qui
restent nous avons des chantiers
importants des réformes importantes à
faire des réformes importantes dans le
domaine de l'économie dans le domaine
sociétal et je pense qu'il n perdu alors
là je constaté hier soir c'est la façon
don offensivement il a parlé de l'avenir
en disant voilà les su sur lesquel nous
allons avancer il pense que des textes
économiques seront plus facile à faire
passer à l'Assemblée qu'un texte sur
l'immigration c'est ça un peu l'idée
texteau bah on a bien vu qu' il y a des
marqueurs à l'Assemblée nationale nous
pensions que que les républicain pouvait
faire preuve de plus de
responsabilitéz quand j'entends dire
quelques-uns l'autre jour que on n pas
cherché à discuter avec les républicains
au début de ce quinquena le chef de
l'État a proposé une coalition
républicain il aur a tendu la main on
leur a tendu la main pour gouverner avec
ils ont refusé ils l'ont rejeté qu'on
dise pas aujourd'hui qu'il ne l'a pas
fait mais est-ce que vous allez
continuer à faire parce que sur les vous
avez discuté avec eux ça s'est terminé
en 493 là vous avez cherché à discuter
avec eux ça se termine en motion de
rejet est-ce que vous allez continuer à
discuter avec les républicains où est-ce
que vous dites maintenant ça suffit non
mais on va toujours discuter avec tout
le monde bien entendu sans être DUP sur
ce qui arrive aujourd'hui j'ai compris
que la position de Monsieur CTI la
position de Monsieur marlex qui
aujourd'hui en plus sur ce texte au-delà
même du gain politique sont dans une
dans une situation de règlement de
compte on voit bien qu'ils en veulent
terriblement à Gérald daranin qu'ils
veulent lui faire payer son riment à la
majorité alors au-delà même de ne pas
s'intéresser aux questions de la société
réelle et des solutions pour notre pays
ils règlent encore leur compte en plus
ce qui est vraiment une attitude
politique que je ne peux absolument pas
aujourd'hui approuver mais vous dites
Emmanuel Macron garde intacte sa volonté
de réformer sa volonté d'avancer est-ce
qu'il fait pas un peu comme si rien ne
s'était passé lundi pour vous c'est
juste une péripétie parlementaire bien
entendu que la situation aujourd'hui est
grave tout le monde le sait ce qui s'est
passé c'est un acte grave avant c'est
cette cette coalition contre nature
cette alliance de la carpe et du lapin
entre l'extrême droite et l'extrême
gauche ça me rappelle des des moments de
l'histoire où les deux extrêmes se
rejoignent pour créer le chaos et après
se divise parce qu'elles sont d'accord
sur rien vous avez compris que les
filles et les font leemal ne sont
d'accord sur rien et les républicains
sont encore pas d' sont d'accord ni
avec ni avec théoriquement ni avec
théoriquement le rassemblement national
et il vote avec eux ils votent avec eux
pourquoi pour créer du chaos et de la
difficulté et pour refuser de répondre à
CZ la dernière fois il y avait dans les
oppositions tout le monde nous disait
attention vous allez voter un texte
contre la volonté d'une majorité de
Français aujourd'hui une majorité de
Français souhaite que ce texte passe
approuve les mesures du gouvernement
alors l'argument on le retourne pas mais
là là l'opinion publique on doit rien en
faire s'il y a une coalition comme ça
des oppositions c'est parce qu'il y a
des iritant pour tout le monde dans ce
texte est-ce que c'est pas la limite du
en même temps qu'a souhaité Emmanuel
Macron
et notamment dans ce texte moi j'ai du
mal à comprendre de vouloir faire un
texte un texte qui est équilibré qui à
la fois dans le même temps
permet attendez qui permet mais est-ce
que c'est pas une volonté démocratique
intelligente et positive de vouloir
faire quelque chose qui soit équilibré
dans une situation difficile de dire il
faut expulser des gens aujourd'hui il
faut les mettre hors d'état de nuire il
faut régler un problème
d'immigration d'accord mais j'entends
bien mais ok donc il y aurait pu avoir
de textte effectivement c'est pas le
choix qui a été retenu en disant est-ce
qu'enfin l'intelligence et la chagesse
vont l'emporter sur les guerres
picrocolines c'est ça ben non enfin
c'est surtout parce que les LR ne
voulait pas de texte il parlait de
saucissonnage saissonnage non mais alors
alors ils ne veulent pas de texte et le
jour où il y en a qu'un ils n veulent
pas non plus alors donc ça veut dire
qu'ils veulent rien voilà est-ce que la
seule solution aujourd'hui c'est la
dissolution bah écoutez l'hypothèse a
été écartée moi je elle a été révoqué
soir vous avez rediscuté hier soir le
président de la République a clairement
dit hier soir que l'hypothèse d'une
dissolution sur un sujet comme ça
aujourd'hui évidemment comm comme
l'immigration était exclu parce parce
que le contexte effervescent épidermique
qu'il crée aujourd'hui fait qu'on ne
réponde pas à la question par ailleurs
que donc le chef de l'État l'ayant
lui-même écarté à juste titre il craint
que ce soit un gain pour le
rassemblement national pour être cl à
juste titre il a écarté donc maintenant
les choses sont claires C mais vous vous
dites à juste titre alors qu' il y a
quelques jours vous disiez un moment
viendra où la dissolution devra
s'imposer j'ai dit j'ai dit que dans les
hypothèses j'ai évoqué les hypothèses si
vraiment c'était le chaos si vraiment la
blocage était total on va on va le voir
dans dans l'avenir si sont les textes
que j'aiévoqué à l'instant j'ai parler
de la fin de vie mais d'autres textte si
demain vraiment le blocage était
manifeste sur ce texte là c'est un texte
spécifiqueent qui crée de la difficulté
on le voit bien qui crée un moment de
gravité dans ce pays mais je vous dis
qu' n'est pas propre à la France qui est
propre à tous les pays européens sur ce
ce sujet ce sujet je pense que c'est pas
le sujet qui prête aujourd'hui la
dissolution mais le fait de la
dissolution c'est vrai que j'ai dit
qu'une qu'une dans ma grande en tout cas
le temps politique que j'ai connu qui
est un temps long une situation avec une
majorité comme ça c'est difficile que ça
dure c'est vrai qu'est-ce qu'Emmanuel
Macron peut faire aujourd'hui pour
rebondir il a évoqué il y a quelques
jours une initiative en janvier pour
rassembler le pays est-ce qu'il vous en
a dit plus hier soir hier soir non hier
soir on a parlé des text on a parlé du
plein emploi on a parlé de la fin de vie
on a parlé euh de des des textes à mener
pu on a surtout qu'est-ce que vous avez
dit sur la fin de vie juste est-ce que
est-ce qu'il craint que il y ait des des
divisions sur ce texte et jusqu'où il
est prêt aller l'opinion générale qui
s'est dégagé du dîner d'h soir c'est que
les Français sont favorables à un texte
aujourd'hui qui a une demande de la
société française qu'on évolue ce texte
et il a bien dit qu'il prendrait les
choses avec beaucoup d'ordre en parlant
d'abord euh de de l'accompagnement euh
vie et ensuite que le texte sur les
modalités un modèle à la française
d'accompagnement ENF aussi vous allez
avoir un problème de discussion avec les
LR je P je pense qu'il y aura une
discussion avec tout le monde il y aura
il y aura mais ça ve ça veut dire juste
que le texte sur les modalités
c'est-à-dire la question de l'aide
active à mourir à savoir si l'than faut
comprendre qu'elle serait réservé au cas
extrême au cas de gens qui ont des
maladies incurbles dans des souffrances
extrêmes de les accompagner dans le fin
de vie- ça veut dire qu'
parul mais ça veut dire qu'il y a
d'abord un texte avec le plan sur les
soins palliatifs le plan desal sur les
soins palliatif et ensuite un texte déjà
un grand moment de renforcement des
soins palliatifs ça cétit évoqué hier
soir affirmé par le chef de l'État qu'il
a dit on va traiter les soins palliatifs
et ensuite on mettra le texte comme ce
texte et comme ce texte prier premier
trimestre tout de suite d dès maintenant
dès maintenant et comme ce texte mettra
sans doute parce qu'il y aura des
navettes entre ici le débat dans la
société prendra sûrement du temps faudra
sans doute un an pour le voter je pense
que ce textelà pourrait venir après les
européennes aprè il y aura un texte de
loi qui sera présenté en février février
et qui sera débattu après après les
européennes au parl vous avez discuté de
texte de loi qui étit d'ors et déjà
annoncé ça veut dire que les affaires
reprennent comme d'habitude comme s'il
ne s'était rien passé finalement ça veut
dire qu'il faut continuer d'avancer je
pense que le rôle des politique c'est de
continuer à améliorer la société à
trouver des solutions au problèm chaque
jour problème de l'économie comme
important si on veut AR si on veut
arriver par exemple aujourd'hui à ce que
le taux d'emploi qu'on dit toujours le
le plein emploi que le taux d'emploi
augmente faut aujourd'hui par les
souveraineté par les industrialisation
parler parler je crois recherche comme
l'a fait le chef de l'État à Toulouse
cette semaine très important est-ce que
ça veut dire que le chef de l'État
considère que ce qui s'est passé n'est
pas majeur et qu'il n'y a pas besoin
d'un geste fort pour pour dépasser
ça chef de l'État a bien dit hier hier
soir que nous vivions un moment de
gravité ce moment de gravité il fallait
l'analyser mais qu'il fallait trouver le
chemin à la fois à la fois de la de
l'unité et de la et de la marche en
avant un dernier mot puisque vous parlez
des européenes François patria vous
n'avez toujours pas lancé votre campagne
malgré la demande d'éisabeth borne qui
qui dit que qu'il faut y aller est-ce
que c'est le signe que vous avez un
problème d'incarnation non est-ce que le
temps est-ce que le temps de la campagne
est-ce que les Français sont les
européennes aujourd'hui les européennes
ils vont commencer on va en parler
vraiment Bardella lui dans les EUR B est
en campagne en permanence une accès à
faire une accès à faire ça marche
dans ce pays et ben oui mais là vous
décrochez dans les sondages quandme
Renaissance décroche dans les enfin la
majorité redécroche dans les sondages la
dernière fois on nous avait donné
beaucoup plus bas je me souviens des
sondages y compris pour de la République
au mois de janvier au mois de janvier
2017 prés de la République était à 17
Madame Le Pen était à 26 j'avais dit sur
ce plateau que Emmanuel Macron serait
devant madame Le Pen mais là vous pensez
gag les européennes vous pensez être
devant le rassemblement national je fais
pas ce Paris là aujourd'hui d'abord
j'aime pas les Paris comme ça mais je
dis que le sondage qu'on donne
aujourd'hui je crois regardez la
popularité du chef de l'État elle est
contrairement à ce qu'on dit elle tient
elle tient elle tient aujourd'hui on a
un socle autour de 30 %. de 30 % il peut
se traduire aux européennes je dis pas
qu'on fera 30 aux européennes je dis
qu'on peut faire plus qu'on nous produit
aujourd'hui merci Françis patria merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité la Une
de La Dépêche c'est la loi immigration
et maintenant ou c'est la Question à la
Une de votre journal Christelle merci
beaucoup on passe au club de territoire
merci